una situación dramática en la que se
vive en este momento en el sur del país
con los incendios que se declaraban la
jornada de ayer y que han avanzado de
forma muy rápida y en distintos puntos
con varios focos muy activos a la vez
una situación que ha obligado al
gobierno a decretar la zona de
catástrofe que es una medida
administrativa que permite movilizar
todos los recursos a cargo del Estado
para acudir a sofocar esos fuegos más de
150 como bien señalabas de 190 que
existían esta mañana y que han consumido
unas 14.000 hectáreas todavía no hay
datos sobre infraestructura y viviendas
pero si se han visto
imágenes dramáticas dantescas de
personas que tenían que evacuar y que
veían como sus hogares eran llevados por
las llamas y el presidente suspendió sus
vacaciones para ir hasta allí Cuál ha
sido la respuesta del gobierno
el presidente borich suspendió sus
vacaciones se encontraba en el sur del
país en su región en Magallanes y
sobrevoló hasta el bío bío y ñuble para
sobrevolar también las zonas del
incendio en muchos varios ministros se
encuentran desplazados en la zona el
gobierno está en terreno y lo que ha
advertido el presidente que señaló Por
cierto que alguno de estos incendios
Podría tener un origen provocado por
unas llamas No autorizadas que en ese
momento se están concentrando todos los
esfuerzos el sofocar controlar todos
estos incendios que asolan a varias
regiones en el país para una vez
contenido el fuego como ocurrió en Viña
en el mes de diciembre desplegar toda la
ayuda para las familias toda la ayuda
reconstrucción todo el soporte a cargo
del Estado para poder hacer frente a las
numerosas familias que están sufriendo
en este momento por condiciones
climáticas que también han favorecido la
expansión del fuego los vientos y las
altas temperaturas que se viven en chile
y que se esperan este fin de semana